yeah hi I'm Bento I'm here uh a poal
fellow and usually a George and uh I
want to speak about mazes so let's say
we have a maze we are at the top right
corner we are in some domain in Rd
something ukian and we want to find a
treasury at the bottom left corner um
how complicated is that
well this would be a path and um I can
of course make that arbitrarily licated
so if you want to solve a ma then we
need to have some assumptions and um I
work generally in convex optimization so
let's from now on say we have a convex
body we are still in the top right
corner we want to find the treasure and
um because of complexity that's too easy
so we went from far too hard to far too
easy so we need to find something in
between that is interesting and you can
do that by saying okay I still tell you
that there is a treasure but I don't
tell you where I just tell you where to
find it and this is just classical
convex
optimization um and for that we have
tools to do it um efficiently there's
deep Theory how you can solve complex
problems um and um the question that is
still out there is okay I can now very
efficiently approximate my treasure but
I cannot find it exactly at least the
question is how many steps do I need to
find that exactly and there are natural
barriers to that because I didn't tell
you how I Define my convex body it can
be defined by some very annoying uh
convex polinomial where even describing
the treasure would yeah there's no close
form expression for this for describing
the treasure so we even have to make a
bit more assumptions and so let's say
our polinomial is describing the the
body describing the body are just linear
functions so we end up at linear
programming um but still there something
that you have to take care of and that
is I can give you rational numbers that
Define your polytope um and if you want
to find an exact solution then classical
methods wouldn't apply here because they
can go arbitrarily close but you cannot
really jump to the solution to the up
solution okay um and it turns out that
if you have these irrational numbers
then classical methods like interior
Point methods have the same behavior as
the original maze we saw and that you
can require up to two to the end many
pieces to find your optimal solution
okay so the question I'm interested in
is okay what assumptions can you more
make on the structure of your
constraints that you able to find the
optimum solution in polinomial time and
this you can nicely parameterize by some
notion of complexity of the normal
vectors of your constraints and um one
nice result is that if all these vectors
lie on a nice grid than if AOS has shown
almost 40 years ago that you only
require a polinomial number of basic
arithmetic operations to find that
optimal solution and um what we figured
out in joint work with Daniel D cedri Co
um Neil Ola and llo is that if your
vectors are sparse as in your support is
only two dimensions then you can solve
that problem also in strongly Po in
poomi many steps which for people who
know the strongly polinomial world would
mean strongly polinomial time okay and
as a note all linear programs can be
formulated with at most three nonzero
entries per normal Vector so this is
sort of the end of the line of
parameterizing by number of nonzeros
before you solve the whole problem of
strongly polinomial LP okay um and maybe
one application in the end where by
application I mean a theory problem that
can be reduced to uh 29 zos per uh
normal vector and these describe sort of
all graph problems what you can have is
okay we have a bipartite graph um and we
want to assign workers to tasks and um
we have costs of assigning workers to
tasks and these workers let's say have
different ability to do these tasks and
these would be these blue gamma factors
and sort of now we have the first
strongly polinomial time algorithm to
solve this problem uh exactly and uh I
guess that's that's the end thank
[Applause]
you any
questions oh yes just one clarification
with that the result we know that we
have a strongly polom because you say po
many basic arithmetic operations and I'm
not sure you're speaking about
simp yeah I didn't want to go into
computational models the idea is that
you have irrational numbers and the
model would be you can add them multiply
them compare them and that's all you can
do but the number of operations the
number of operations is yes and the
space that you use as well so
[Music]
yeah